there is a class of republicans who are
the court jesters in the kingdom of
liberalism and what they do is they put
up a show a charade of opposition so it
seems like we have a really tough
political system where the two sides are
fighting it out but we don't really we
actually have a dominant ruling
democratic party and then we have some
of their junior partners the the court
chester republicans who go in and they
pretend to fight back but they
ultimately kind of have the same aims
which is why when someone like donald
trump comes along who is offering not
just a different kind of personality but
actually a different set of policies
actually a different political vision
getting tough on trade with our you know
not just having free trade with
everybody getting tough on immigration
not just having open borders right when
donald trump comes along with a
historically much more conservative
much more republican in the old sense of
the word type of platform then all the
court gestures go running
and then they say no this is terrible
this is awful we've got to save our
republic our democracy and they they go
and support the democrats we need real
conservatives there's a there's a great
attack ad right now on one of the real
conservatives out there ron desantis
take a listen to this attack ad tell me
if it if it makes you more or less
likely to vote for ron desantis
ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of your cabin crew we'd like
to inform you that we have officially
entered florida airspace
now that we're making our final descent
please watch this short message from
governor ron desantis on covet 19.
thereafter everyone on board will be
required to comply with the state's
forever purge
we are not doing any vaccine passports
in the state of florida
we trust people to make their own
decisions in this state we are not going
to be bludgeoning people
with restrictions
and mandates
and lockdowns or any of that stuff
as
it is against the law for private
businesses or schools to mandate masks
or vaccines
and you have the absolute right to
infect whoever you want whenever and
wherever with covet 19.
no
ron desantis said that he trusts people
to make their own decisions
no
no people can't the fact that someone
would push this out there as an attack
ad
i wouldn't be surprised if ronda santa
secretly funded this to make him look
cooler okay the fact that a group put
this out there and thinks that this is
an attack ad that ron desantis is going
to let people make their own decisions
not have everyone muzzle themselves and
live in fear shows you just
how radically differently
the two sides
see the world in this country i'm so
glad you enjoyed that clip i would tell
you to watch the whole show on youtube
but youtube keeps censoring me for
stating perfectly plain facts they won't
let me even quote the director of the
cdc because they accuse me of engaging
in medical misinformation when i
directly quote the
the uh director of the cdc so make sure
you go get this show uncensored uncut
with all the facts over at apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play all
the places you get your podcasts for
free it's the michael knowles show or of
course subscribe to dailywire.com
[Music]
[Music]